all right welcome to another edition of
beginner breakdown I am your host Mike
comer and tonight we'll be going over
miss checkmate opportunities so whenever
you have a chance to checkmate your
opponent you should do it because you
don't want to let your opponent come
back and get you so so we'll be going
over some games where unfortunately the
opponents let them slip up so here we go
so white starts out efore black counters
with E 5 right brings out is Knight to
f3 to attack the pawn so black protects
it Knight to c6 Bishop to c4 that
attacks the f7 square f7 square is the
weakest square in chess because it is
only protected by the King and Kings
cannot capture protected pieces so
that's a really good square to hit on in
the opening especially for white so
black plays Knight to f6 this move is
not advisable for beginners because it
allows the knight to come up to g5 and
that puts two attackers on this pivotal
f7 square so if you're playing black in
this position I would try h6 Bishop to
e7 or Bishop to c5 but the move Knight
f6 just allows this Knight to jump in
you see how those moves h6 or Bishop to
e7 or even Bishop to c5 doesn't allow
the knight in because the Queen would
take but this is for beginners if you
know book Knight f6 will be okay okay so
Knight to g5 so now you're in a
predicament already and it's blue 5 you
have to defend f7 because the Knights
attacking it and the bishop and your
only defender is the King so how in the
world can we 6
cessful II defend f7 there is no way to
successfully defend it because if we
bring out the Queen the knight can still
just come and take you're not going to
trade a queen
for two pieces okay to novice players
they have asked to be remained anonymous
for this game but we'll probably let the
but they're both playing in the under
800 division let's just say that yes at
the high school championships yes okay
so so so how can we stop this Bishop
from taking on f7 check or attacking it
anybody have any ideas that are that's
rated under 1,400 all right so so
hopefully at home you guys figure it out
d5 that stops the connection now the
bishop cannot capture on f7 so we'll
take with the pawn we don't want to take
with the bishop because our Bishop is an
attacking piece and we're attacking so
when we're attacking we do not want to
trade off or attacking pieces because if
we took with the bishop the knight could
come and take us all right so we'll take
with the pawn and now our knight is
under attack no questions no questions
all right so there's there's a lot of
different different variations black can
get in here we could take the pawn which
will we'll get into the fried liver
attack on an ensuing episode but right
now we'll say that black plays Knight to
a5 which is what a place okay so now I
think that's a weak move but what should
white do to take advantage of this
situation here anybody have any ideas
okay so so what you should be playing is
Bishop to b5 check okay then he'll black
with the pawn will take hello cláudio
pawn takes and now our Bishop would go
to d3 and we'll put our knight back
there eventually and so that would be a
very successful way and we'll be up a
pawn unfortunately white plays the move
Queen to e2 here protects the the bishop
and attacks that you pawn here but
Knight takes we can't take with check
we'll have to take the knight and we'll
go on from there all right so Knight
takes the pawn
okay so now white plays Knight to c3
should black capture this Knight it's
night for Knight what do you think what
would be wrong with Knight taking the
knight all of a sudden the Queen would
go here and the game would be over okay
so so this Knight is in like a pin the
button is any of whites pieces
undefended right now the knight so we
can just take it okay and then we'll
take their Knight and now we're also
protecting g2 here so Bishop comes down
and attacks the knight very bad move for
black so a way a tactics arise in the
game of chess is undefended pieces
notice this Bishop is undefended
especially if they're undefended pieces
in your territory that's when you really
want to look for tactics look the
bishops all by himself in your territory
pieces closest to pieces pieces close to
other pieces are more likely to be able
to attack them and strike them and all
get them so so we could easily attack
the bishop like this but then he'd be
like oh my bishop the tag I better just
take your knight or move away okay so we
need a forcing move to also attack the
bishop so like a double attack for
instance so who else can we attack here
besides the bishop
how about so we want to attack the
bishop with our most powerful piece the
Queen it's pretty close to here so we
could attack it like this like this or
excellent we go to b5 check all right
now the King is under attack and the
bishop double attack very powerful move
in chess okay but white doesn't see this
they decide we better get castle that's
the most important thing in just
castling but that's not right the most
important thing is winning material and
winning the game okay so so black
decides I'm gonna threaten checkmate but
are they really threatening checkmate in
this position the answer is no because
Queen takes g2 would not be checkmate
because the Queen is protecting g2 but
if we can deflect the Queen from the
protection black will be in business
okay all right so white plays d3 very
sneaky move it's a discovered attack the
bishop is now aiming at the Queen all
right so the Queen moves all right so so
white decides she doesn't like that
Queen sitting so close to her in g4 I
better attack it all right so what's a
really bad way for a white to attack
the Queen f3 uh-oh
so the move f3 broke the connection
between the Queen and the pawn on g2 so
obviously black should checkmate
but unfortunately black doesn't see it
his whole plan was the checkmate but I
guess he lost sight of it for a second
and he retreated to g6 no take-backs
were allowed so white decides it could
just protect it now but I might as well
take pawn with check first
now yep the players were beginners just
like just like you and me here so rook
to f2 stops the checkmate Bishop attacks
the Queen Queen to e4 tries to get the
Queen's off the board so they oblige
opens that F file so now black knows hey
my bishops under tech there's no longer
this G pawns no longer pin I better move
it not to there though bishop back to e6
okay so now he gets his pawns rolling he
decides not to trade i keep to keep the
attack going so the bishop retreats he
gets the UH he gets the F pawn so things
are going pretty well for white now then
a black failed to check made them so
Bishop check King over so now the bishop
in a pin takes the knight takes double
pawns
alright so bishops in a pin let's try to
attack it so fortunately they don't but
maybe maybe an idea like e5 was good
there but Bishop check pretty good too
because now this rook
we'll be trapped back on the back on a8
so he really wanted to get his rook out
when he when he had the chance because
now after this check King has to go back
to c8 and box that rook in so now the
pollens are going and white is in
control of this game
Rilke taxed the bishop and he decides or
she decides just to ignore it because if
takes we'll just yeah we'll take it with
the Brooke and just keep keep our to
keep our pawns nice and protected yeah
they're both pretty good but anyhow
besides Bishop to a4 and now white is in
the driver's seat here so now here's
another example of white whites now in
control she has a checkmate the computer
says checkmate in 11 or 13 here but it's
a pretty simple win here you play check
alright they go here and now you got the
pawn the pawn fort attacking the king
and the rook take and now the game the
game's essentially over okay
the Europe a whole rook looks good so so
now black had a chance to checkmate
and now White has had a chance to
checkmate so they both both missed it
cause instead of playing check they're
gonna play Bishop to d6 setting up a
delayed attack a delayed discovery okay
it's better to just attack and don't
don't wait for it to happen
so now rook attacks the bishop bishop
takes rook takes all right
you see king and rook lined up on the
same lane and so she gets really excited
and plays rook to e8 Jack unfortunately
this is not the best move the intentions
were good but unfortunately that square
is covered by the bishop and nothing
like a free rook
so now white is in trouble black is
smart it tries to get the hop on right
away because this is the only guy that
could possibly cause any more troubles
for a black here so b5 so White's in
trouble here so once black gets this
pawn off the board it should be smooth
sailing they sail take all the rest of
his pawns and then yeah he black out it
and so so there's not much hope for
white here but he could still like take
this pawn and try
alright so white attack the rook but
then he put in the pin so if you take
the rook black will just come down and
capture White's rook so does not want to
trade so it brings the King up pieces in
a pin put an extra attacker on it so
they the size just not banning the
bishop and it's not gonna last much
longer
well so so they take the pawn and it
could take the oh did it take the better
but it's not exactly free rook takes
King takes
and so so now they got the easy way to a
check made a king with the two rooks is
you just line them up war no rank apart
just go up and there's nothing white can
do except get checkmated so so let's see
if our Stuart does any better on the
next game our hero in this game is uh is
black but there are no heroes in this
game unfortunately as you'll see black
will miss a mate white will miss a mate
and then who knows how the end of the
game will go okay so white starts out
efore black plays d6 yes but both both
are rated under a thousand black is
rated around six hundred whites by way
around 800 900 okay so a real real good
game you're a good game to learn from
you want to learn from these guys
mistakes so you're not doing them okay
that's why we show you these games in
the beginner breakdown we could show you
Grand Master games where Grand Master
you plays so good so good and you'd be
like I wish I could play like that but I
can't but by by seeing these blunders
you can be like well that get was pretty
funny how that guy messed up like that
I'm not gonna mess up you can put that
in your game not messing up but good
moves good moves take a lot of hard work
you got to read a lot of books got to
play a lot of games to get good good
like that
alright so so black plays the perk
defense we saw this last week and how to
beat it so notice how white is not
playing along this diagonal here and
putting the bishop and queen in a berry
so it makes a pretty easy game for a
black not to get checkmated and just to
play a normal game here
so white castle's it gets gets there
pretty quick black plays 'if I've but
how many players is are attacking how
many players does black have defending
'if I've not enough you need you need as
many defenders as he has attackers
unfortunately he's got one two three
attackers and you only have two
defenders so so the math doesn't really
add up for you to play e5 so you got to
prepare your moves you can't just play
and hope it's a simple math actually
just have as many defenders as he has
attackers c5 so takes obviously take
take back black also takes back Oh
all right and so so white white then
took the knight and now black plays b6
okay so now White has another
opportunity to win a pawn he already won
one on e5 and now he's got a second
chance so there's a tactic in chest
called removing the defender okay so
notice White's Bishop on e5 is attacking
c7 but it wouldn't be smart to take it
now because the Queen would take the
queen is acting as a defender so if we
remove the defender we can take the pawn
for free so now everybody should have
the answer
Queen takes d8 so rook takes and now
we're free to take the pawn and now his
rook is attacked
so now rook attacks the bishop bishop
retreats it gets his last piece off the
back row there Bishop to b7 so double
attacking the pawn so let's see if white
protects the pawn so I think it plays a
pretty nifty move here rook to e1 not so
nifty
and now black gets his rook behind it
all right so now he pushes the pawn he
prepared be prepared e5 by putting his
rook behind it all right so now the
knight is under attack Knight to g4 so
now he's got one two three attackers and
white only has two okay so so we only
have two defenders of this pond and he
has three attackers so what move should
white play not only to save the pawn but
get initiative get get an attack on
anybody have any guesses all right
Julian ye6 good so now II 6 does a lot
of stuff it attacks the rook and attacks
this pawn with check for King the king
and the rook okay so so now black sees a
double attack here he pounds the move
rook the d4 all right now both the
bishops are under attack
both undefended but unfortunately that's
all nice and good for black that he's
attacking two of White's pieces but he
left his King exposed to a check and
left himself exposed to a mate in three
everybody see how he can get a maid in
three here you want to go ahead Oh No
okay well okay so so if you can't find
wait if you do in puzzle books and you
can't find a maid in three made and two
you should always look for your checks
okay the most forcing moves checks
captures okay
so so let me ask you you can't find the
maid in three but can you find the one
check on the board yeah point pawn takes
f7 Shack okay so you find the check and
then you can find the mate okay average
there there's more than one checks you
can just go through the variations but
there's only one check on the board so
that's probably how it's gonna start
okay so pawn takes pawn check if I go
here and now can you find a mate in one
yeah yeah and guess what any check you
do is not is not checkmate actually oh
yeah f1 to e8 yeah dad des checkmate
also a checkmate is rook here okay so
he's got two pretty simple mates here
okay all right and that's how you have
to look you just look for the checks and
hopefully they lead to mate they don't
always but sometimes they do so so
unfortunately white got a little a
little funny here decided I don't want
to lose this light square bishop it's
being so good to me so he attacks the
rook and now black doesn't miss the
opportunity here to get that mischievous
pawn off the board and stop him from
getting checkmated so white now takes on
4j and black takes back all right so now
he's still got to deal with this bishop
so why not attack a pod way down there
because it cuz we really need him okay
we didn't need to get the King but well
we need this a 7-point so black decides
the counter-attack here so so this book
is is attacking f2
alright alright if he gets his rook over
here or Knight down there this could be
some trouble for him okay so what's an
interesting move that white can do to
prevent prevent them from taking this
punt I was in the game they played f3
which you don't want to force your pawns
in front of your King sight unless you
absolutely have to so if a beginner or
if anybody under 1400 gets the right
answer here
they might get a special prize tonight
what is a really cool way cuz cuz this
Knight is really bugging you he's down
your territory this rook down there so
you can stop them from taking something
on f2 and maybe even harass this Knight
a little bit anybody got any guesses you
want to take a guess Bishop to e2 very
good see that's a dual-purpose move okay
it stops the connection between the rook
and the pawn and now if he doesn't move
the knight will take it yes no is it
going to be checkmate
well Knight to e2 I mean that's also
kind of cool but but the Bishop II all
right another suggestion was rook to d1
but uh but who knows so there's a lot of
good moves I mean everything is a good
move Bishop to e2 was just the best
because it tells the knight to go away
and and now the rooks not doing much
okay but the move in the game is f3
attacks the night alright so so now the
night
now that the pawn is on f3 instead of f2
the knight can happen to a nice square
here alright and now he's attacking the
g2 point so he takes he decides up and
we're just straight pawn for pawn what's
what's the heart what's the hurt in that
well there's a lot of hurt in that okay
so now he's in check he's got to move to
h1 and now black can try to put on the
finishing touches here with a good move
here hopefully everybody at home so a
good move may as well take and now this
King's got no place to go anyway that
rook goes it's gonna be check okay so
hey he took he took a poem with his
Bishop I'll take upon with his Bishop
okay so now so now if you count up a lot
of your checks you'll see a really good
move for black yep there's actually
three different checkmates in this
position for black believe it or not
so you got about nine checks here with
the rook three of them are checkmate
hey everybody see the checkmate yeah
which one work the g1a fortunately does
not do the trick because it lets the
king capture so okay so that's one out
of nine not the checkmate rook to g3
checkmate all right you can play rook
here or work here
route the g3 he can't take the route
cause the bishop is delivering the check
but black plays unfortunately rook takes
see two misses the checkmate just like
white missed the checkmate now black
gets the missed the checkmate all right
so so King to g1 so now so now black
kind of made a mistake
he should have he obviously should have
checkmated but he can go back in time if
he wants it's not often in chess you can
go back in time but but look at this
you're going right back in time all
right and then you could even take more
stuff check them again just keep going
and now get the checkmate but but right
but you never want to miss a checkmate
it's very very very sobering experience
so don't don't do that so so after black
plays Knight to d5 so he's moving his
Knight away from the king and
so it's kind of falling apart for him
now so takes takes rook takes so a lot
of stuff just went down there and it
leaves a leaves weight down a piece so
we'll go through that real quick here so
so after Knight to d5 Bishop rook took
and now he protected his knight Knight
took Bishop takes but then the Bishop
was left undefended removing the
defender so Bishop the e1 so now Bishop
to e5 so who likes black to win in this
position so who likes white to win in
this position who's gonna vote for a
draw so so be an interesting endgame
here so rook rook double attacks the
pawn and pawns so he saves that one but
loses the a pawn bishop check King here
and now and now black has another
opportunity the checkmate
and decides he rather he rather just put
his rook so close so close so Bishop
takes rook takes and now black can that
deliver the checkmate right there
alright so now he attacks the pin piece
so Bishop to g6 white decides he's not
gonna trade the rook because if he
trades the last remaining piece it will
be a loss Bishop here King up
all right so black decides I'm just
gonna get my pawns going right now rook
attacks the bishop it takes check all
right King up h5 all right so now rook
there so who can so it looks like oh
there's no way white can stop or black
and stop white from taking this point so
does anybody have an interesting way he
can protect the G pond
do you got it alright how oh look the f3
check great and then rook up
alright that's very interesting but
black decides something a little funnier
he gets a little more creative really
doesn't want to lose this pawn so he
decide or she decides actually I'll just
put my bishop in front of it because she
figures if she loses those two pawns she
won't be able to checkmate him rook and
Bishop against the rook so the sides are
and I just get rid of that barrier but
it wasn't doing much anyway and I still
got my two connected passed pawns
alright so black
they'll thinking everything's great and
now unfortunately he got too excited
with the pawns and now White has the
double attack on brick and all the hard
work of black has gone away just comes
and then I don't know how much longer
the game goes but it was decided a draw
black doesn't trade but but it goes on
and on and on
- it drew yes it's an actual game I
didn't just create it off the top of my
head no no unfortunately unfortunately
for me I did not all right so now we're
gonna see one one final game from our
hero in this in this block of games
where she actually sees a checkmate and
does it so we'll give her a big round of
applause at the end when she finally
gets it and so now she is playing white
and she she decides when she sees the
perk played as we saw in last week's
edition she plays it pretty good of how
to to attack the park so this should all
be a refresher from last week we get our
Queen and Bishop it in a battery and now
we just want to try to just break up
this dragon position right away no it's
great
so whenever they play e5 we just want to
push the pawn we don't want to give
flack any counterplay here
c6 so Knight f3 I don't really agree
with h4 is a is recommended highly
recommended
Knight to f3 so now black just get some
counter play here we want our pawn on f3
in these scenarios not our night alright
so now white is kind of sidetracked from
attacking and getting the King so now h4
take with the knight Knight to b6
decides to retreat the knight
so now h5 so Knight attacks the Queen so
the queen is now protecting the pawn the
bishop so when they play Queen to c1
black sea's away to remove the defender
via of this pawn bishop takes so now the
Queen has to come up and now Knight
takes but this is a pretty dangerous
spot for this Queen pretty close to your
King once they get the H file open
checkmate could be right around the
corner so so kind of unwise for black to
let White's Queen all the way up there
so so white tries to get right up there
get rid of this Knight remove the
defender of h7 so black doesn't care
rook take C - so pawn takes so this is
getting H file is now open so white
white has a lot of go counter place so
Queen to a5 check King to f1 and now
black kind of freaks out here okay it's
never good to freak out it's better to
calculate than freak out okay so he's
like oh my god I'm about to get
checkmated there's nothing I can do
there's always something you could
probably do in chess
unless you calculate out of every single
variation and then you see you lost and
then you just try a Hail Mary anyway
okay but in this instance white is not
really threatening a checkmate let's say
black skips a turn okay
all right let's let's say they take
let's let's say this skip let's let's
say they play it good okay
like pawn here okay all right
never skip okay so so they're thinking
Knight takes Knight removing the
defender e7 rook takes check King here
check let's play King here rook check I
keep the checks do we want to play King
here no because then well it's white
really gonna see the made them mate and
actually that's not even the mate that's
funny
this is the mate right but however their
ball it's gonna end lead to mate all
right so so X so after this check black
can just family retreat his rook back to
f7 and there's no checkmate okay so in
chess even though it looks dire you want
to calculate out and make sure before
you try anything crazy
so black tries something crazy cuz he
he's almost sure he's gonna get
checkmated here so so he takes the pawn
with Chuck alright whenever your
opponents are giving away free material
just take all right that's the best
advice I can give you so Knight check
King up and now he does it anyway and
now he just doesn't have a rook so some
bad news for him Knight check and now
he's so sure they that's still gonna be
checkmate that he decides to run away
with his King alright so black doesn't
want to just our white doesn't want to
just keep giving away his material so
takes with the knight it threatens the
rook rook moves Knight check
King up Queen so good she's just now she
is threatening well not quite a
checkmate but but threatening the rook
threatening the rook in this and this
check that could lead to checkmate
maybe doubtful so White's last move was
Queen up so Queen h4 is another idea
here putting the Queen Knight and King
in the same Lane threatening uh
threatening a lot of good stuff but but
that doesn't threaten her Brooke so she
decides I've got the redness Brooke all
right sir Brooke moves and so now she
decides to threaten another checkmate
here all right so what what move can
white make in this position to threaten
a checkmate a real checkmate not all
this hocus-pocus stuff all right
rook h6 boom all right and that's what
it's played in the game is black gonna
be able to defend this yeah the black
actually has one good defense that's why
you don't freak out you look and then if
you're playing somebody right at under a
thousand they probably won't find it I
found it it's not rook to g8
so that's the clue rook to g8 only only
stops it for so long
what other move can we do to try to stop
this checkmate if you don't find it nope
you're gonna lose a lot of games if you
can't play you can't find a defense oh
so nice to go we just ask yourself a
question if you can't if you have a
trouble fine you ask yourself question
all right
to defend g6 I need to defend g6 how can
I defend g6 can my pawn on a7 defends
you six no can my queen on all the way
over here to offend it no bummer can my
rook
yes but it's horrible my king's already
defend it so who's left the knight and
then you're like night you better defend
it or else I'm out of options
oh look I can put out my knight up here
yay and then I can play some defense bet
on four she's like well I don't see your
way out of it I might as well attack and
hope they missed the checkmate for they
are umpteenth time the knight but they
knew what they were doing this time and
they completed the checkmate yep just
isn't supposed to be a comedy it's
supposed to be good moves - checkmate
your opponent and be very very accurate
yes but this time they made it and they
got the full point congratulations to
them all and thank you all for coming
all right